welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
eternals a literally groundbreaking game
changer with scales so epic that even
the main characters are like woof do we
need all of us for this i loved how this
movie redefined the mythology in the
rules of the mcu so i am gonna break
this down scene by scene for all of the
easter eggs visual details cinematic
influences and deeper layers of meaning
that you might have missed by the way
you can support new rockstars by
checking out our eternals inspired
latest obsession shirt immortal unity
the really cool art deco design at new
rockstarsmerch.com available only for a
limited time though there's also a
fearsome celestial shirt available check
out all of our great options at
newrockstarsmerge.com the film opens
with the words in the beginning just
that text simply on black which of
course the first three words of the
bible establishing this film as its own
book of genesis origin story for the
marvel cinematic universe there's
mention of the universe's first son and
eresham a celestial the god of this
universe and when ecological disaster
wipes out our civilization so that all
that's left is a disney plus
subscription watched by a wally robot
what advanced alien races think our god
is too this star wars-esque scroll says
the celestials came before the six
singularities and the dawn of creation
referring to the infinity stones that
wong explained were created by the big
bang meaning the celestials predated the
big bang and might have created the
infinity stones and were likely
unaffected by thanos snap the number six
apparently sacred of the mcu might have
even be rooted in the celestials having
their six eyes celestials were marvel
comics creations of jack kirby their
giant armored space gods who created
mankind on earth alongside eternals and
deviants in guardians of the galaxy we
briefly saw the celestial east on the
searcher and nowhere is the severed head
of a celestial and peter quill's father
ego claimed to be a celestial as well
here we meet the ten eternals as they
float past the sun in their ships called
the domo in the eternal's comics domo
was actually the name of an eternal who
administered the affairs on olympia
answering directly to zuros athena's
father used to be a secretary now he's a
ship that gets wrecked nomodomo but we
already know something is different
about the eternal's origin story in this
film because they arrive to earth
already manufactured we later hear that
they think they come from a separate
planet called olympia when in the comics
the celestials create the eternals on
earth from genetic experiments alongside
humans and deviants and olympia is a
place on earth as well who maybe do you
know what that's worth so seeing them
just delivered here and then booted up
all just little clues that these are
actually synthetic beings with no real
genetic history alongside humanity and
were just fed this false narrative
throughout all this composer ramin
jawadi scores the imagery with haunting
organ music evoking han zimmer's organ
score for interstellar both of which
cast all this cosmic imagery with the
tones of a church inviting us to behold
these sacred events with reverence and
awe the domo looms into view upon
ancient mesopotamia 5000 bc director
chloe zhao's imagery showing the domo in
profile as a rectangular shape evokes
the mysterious arrival of the monolith
in stanley kubrick's 2001 a space
odyssey which symbolically served the
same function as the domo does here
advanced tech coming from above allowing
early humans to finally evolve an
amphibious deviant washes up much like
the seminal first fish that jumped from
water to land in our evolutionary
history but unlike the deviants in the
comics these have a silvery wispy
anatomy like the barbs of a catfish it's
gonna sting ya it's all strung together
into these mythological forms like
griffins and dragons and notice how they
come with a second set of eyes four in
total which links them visually to the
celestials whose helmets have six eye
circles the deviants just being one
wrong below from that and then eternals
and humans one rung below that with just
the two eyes just another cool detail
hinting that the deviants were also
crafted in the celestial's image and
might have in a way at one point been
preferred this fisherman calmly tells
his son to run sacrificing himself to
save his boy it's just interesting how
despite the eternal's divine gifts after
gifts really the best most noble
qualities about humanity are already
evident in these humans the eternals
help them repel the deviants each using
their powers in different ways like we
see icarus flight and laser vision
makari super speed kingos finger gun
energy blast cersei's matter
transfiguration venus casting of weapons
gilgamesh's power punches fast doses
tech assembly sprites illusion casting
drinks mind control and then ajax last
but not least heals icarus wounds and
notice how whenever they use their
powers they all kinda take the same form
a glow of golden cosmic magic emanating
from the contours of their armor and
actually you can even see makari's
trailing behind her as she zips that boy
to safety almost like a puppet string
just a way of showing how all of this is
just rooted from the celestials like a
string of christmas lights all strung
from the same wall outlet they say
goodbye by giving this boy this dagger
this is actually a real-life ceremonial
golden dagger recovered from the
sumerian port city of er in a royal tomb
so making this village that very
civilization the sumerians were the
earliest known civilization of ancient
mesopotamia living among the tigris and
euphrates river valleys which was one of
four major waterways on earth that early
civilizations arose upon along with the
nile the indus and the yellow river this
film suggests that the spark that
enabled all of human civilization to
ignite was the eternal's arrival and
zhao frames that spark with this handoff
evoking michelangelo's creation of adam
god on the right man on the left the
marvel studios title card actually opens
with a quick flash of kirby's comic
depictions of the six side celestial we
also see sheng chi added to the m of
marvel studios then we hear the music of
pink floyd's time the opening track to
their epic album dark side of the moon
really the best song to just space out
to the lyrics limit losing track of time
kicking around on a piece of the ground
waiting for someone or something to show
you the way
just like how the eternals have been
stuck on earth burning time centuries
millennia waiting for further
instructions from the celestials
cersei's now in london working at the
natural history museum where that
sumerian dagger is now a relic on
display on her way into work she greets
charles darwin whose theory on evolution
might have been eternal inspired she
also gives an apprehensive look at a
dinosaur fossil almost as if these
previous apex predators on earth might
have become prey to their mortal enemies
the deviants in a classroom dane whitman
quotes the poet walt whitman in this
broad earth of ours amid the measureless
grossness and slag enclosed and safe
within its central heart nestles the
seed of perfection going on to say that
the poet's optimism and humanity echoes
our recent universal victory the return
of half our population of course he's
referencing the events of the blip and
avengers end game but also this quote
foreshadows how in our earth within its
heart nestles the seed of a celestial
cersei of course lectures about apex
predators foreshadowing the return of
the apex predator's deviants then at
dayne's birthday party cersei gives dane
a ring that he notices from the middle
ages and it bears a raven emblem dane
whitman becomes in the comics the black
knight a successor to a long line of
warriors who all bear the ebony blade
the first bearer being dane's ancestor
sir percy escandia who lived during the
reign of king arthur cersei says this
raven is his family crest in the comics
black knight's chest blade bears a raven
emblem dane asks cersei are you a wizard
like doctor strange i'm super normal
first these powers come from the
celestials but the eldritch magic of
doctor strange and the sorcerers may
very well come from the same source
later actually cersei transfigures a
boulder into birds visually similar to
how doctor strange turned one of
thanos's attacks into butterflies in
infinity war the deviant attacks them in
camden lock and sprite tries to distract
it by casting duplicates of herself and
cersei though notice how when the
deviant knocks her down it breaks the
illusion and the duplicates fade away
now sprite's duplicates aren't tangible
like the duplicates that loki can cast
with his sorcery so iris arrives to help
and cersei turns a crashing
double-decker bus into rose petals
cersei finally admits to dane the truth
about the eternal's history claiming her
understanding that she came from a
planet called olympia and dane asks why
didn't you guys help fight thanos or any
war all the other terrible things
throughout history we were instructed
not to interfere in any human conflicts
unless the events are involved she goes
on to say that had they protected
humanity from everything mankind would
never develop the way that they were
meant to and to be clear thanos is an
eternal born with a deviant gene he is
the son of alars who was brother tuzarus
thena's father and thanos was also the
brother to aeros aka star fox as
confirmed in the post-credits scene but
it sounds like these eternals were kept
in the dark mostly on earth so they
would probably have no reason to know
thanos's eternal or his deviant lineage
dane hears the name icarus and cites the
greek myth of icarus who flew too close
to the sun and cersei confirms that
sprite made up that myth when they were
in athens so all of the eternals really
have analogs in real world history like
icarus inspired the tragedy of icarus
athena inspired athena greek goddess of
war and leader of athens fastos inspired
hephestos greek god of the forge cersei
inspired cersei from greek mythology in
the odyssey who transforms humans into
animals ajax inspired ajax the hero
second only to achilles gilgamesh
inspired the great epic of gilgamesh
from sumerian mythology considered the
oldest narrative of human history sprite
inspired figures like sprites from
european mythology but also as stated in
this film tinkerbell which is the night
of the comics in which sprite actually
visits playwright j.m barry and inspired
him for his character of peter pan kingo
may have been linked with king goo from
babylonian mythology and druid doesn't
really seem to have a mythological link
but his name does sound like the russian
word droog her friend maybe the way he
sees himself as a friend of humanity but
back in cersei and sprites flat mcu news
outlet whia shows back up on the tv
reporting on the global earthquakes and
sprite unsheathes this blade the same
blade she later uses to stab cersei in
the back during the final battle we
flash back to the city of babylon in 575
bc the film actually reconstructed the
famous ishtar gate currently on display
at the pergamon museum in berlin and
after they slay this deviant ajak is
summoned by the celestial ereshim the
judge and without visually chloe zhao
achieves this awesome scale with
ayrshim's whole design asteroids and
other space dust orbiting his massive
form also notice how his armor in many
places appears scratched crumbled
weathered giving him a semblance of age
and life experience at least compared to
jamaica's cleaner armor in the later
shot like these might be battle scars
from uh kind of conflict that left
nowhere beheaded this first shot of
eresham actually only shows part of his
enormous head like it's impossible for
us to take him in all at once but they
personify him only through his voice and
these six glowing eye holes so later in
the film as tiamat emerges and airshim
returns in judgement just those six eyes
alone signal to us how massive these
things are in full now the domo is
parked inside of the city of babylon
inside the hanging gardens of babylon
which is one of the seven wonders of the
ancient world two other ancient wonders
the lighthouse of alexandria and the
pyramids of giza appeared in the mcu in
loki at the peace sprite regales them in
what sounds like the actual epic of
gilgamesh as makari barters for the
emerald tablet which is a real world
relic containing cryptic hermetic text
which has been obsessed over by islamic
and european alchemists who associated
it with the philosopher's stone as a
means of producing gold but it contains
the famous derived passage of as above
so below which is interesting to think
about the context of the celestials
right as they are above so they are
below our feet sleeping in that
celestial timit begins gold but is
turned back into an elemental form of
marble stone ironic considering dane
calls cersei king midas later on icarus
and cersei declare their love for each
other they get it on and they get
married in the gupta empire of impea in
480. there's actually a quick shot of
the great wall of india at kambelgar the
second longest wall in the world after
the great wall of china i like how in
the shot of the other eternals cheering
on their wedding sprite looks pissed
with envy of course and fina gives an
apprehensive stare as she never fully
trusted icarus cersei's bright nicoras
arrive at ajax south dakota ranch icarus
is the last one to walk up though
probably since he knows what they're
gonna find there then the speaking
sphere floats up from ajax corpse to
cersei and now airshim tells cersei it's
almost time to be disqualified then we
flash back to
sorry if i said that wrong 15 21 a.d
this was the great capital of the aztec
empire that was sacked by spanish forces
led by conquistador hernan cortes in
this year another important historical
turning point in human history it allows
spain and other european powers to end
up dominating the americas thanks
smallpox oh my god i just realized
that's the same way florida's gonna
conquer all of us anyway seeing these
spanish soldiers wipe out the aztecs
with firearms the eternals debate
intervention and then venus suffers a
breakdown from mad weary which they
later define as one's mind fracturing
under the weight of memories like you
know anytime you think about high school
and the spiral lane begins the
skateboarders were so cruel we're all
gonna die ajak offers to wipe thena's
memory but gilgamesh says he will
seclude her and watch over her and then
druid splits off by making the spanish
and aztecs drop their weapons and follow
him into the jungle they track down
kingo on the set of a bollywood film in
mumbai and he tells him his movie is the
legend of icarus thus his costume
matching icarus's old design and he
introduces my favorite character in the
movie karoo actually when we first met
he thought i was a vampire and he tried
to stake me through the heart i've
apologized so many times not quite
enough times very closely i guess
another mcu vampire mentioned after one
we heard in loki you know we brought in
cree
titans vampires why is it the two orphan
demigods are such a pain in the ass just
interesting how vampires are
increasingly becoming the thing in the
mcu setting the stage four blade to
exist at some point a promise that gets
delivered in the final seconds of the
post-credits scene with a vocal cameo by
mahershala ali as the mcu's blade kingo
joins them despite having a sequel to
shoot and he mentions how they just got
bts to do a cameo which i feel like has
got to be a meta nod to the pop star
cameo in this movie's post-credits scene
of a superhero franchise on kingo's
private jet he collects captain
america's original shield from the first
cap film he also shows his movie posters
in which he poses multiple generations
of his own phony dynasty like his great
grandfather his grandfather's father et
cetera the movies include titles like
yuva prim taliko kell and phantom gun
looks like a double 07 type movie but
notice how he changed up the facial hair
of each generation and if you think
about it this would have been under a
hundred years of history so five
generations means that kingo refused to
wait too long before reintroducing
himself as like a younger better looking
son it's so funny he like craves the
spotlight that much cersei tells kingo
in carroon's documentary that she can
turn rock into water rock into wood and
rock into metal could be a bit of
foreshadowing and final act when she
transformed the gold colored metal back
into marble rock but also maybe you
could see this as a way that she could
have helped turn rock into vibranium
with her investos helping the wakandans
in various ways now before i continue
getting called sir or ma'am or dude is
not as cool as getting called lord or
lady established titles is a project
based on a historic scottish custom
where landowners are referred to as
lairds or lords and ladies in english
they let people buy as little as one
square foot of dedicated land so that
they can call themselves a lord or a
lady and in return established titles
commits to planting a tree it's just a
fun way to help preserve the beautiful
woodlands and biodiversity of scotland
while raising funds to support global
conservation efforts established titles
work with global charity trees for the
future and one tree planted to help them
plant a tree for every order plus for
those with scottish heritage it's a
great way to connect to your family
roots or just a great fun option to get
as a gift for a loved one so this is the
title i got i i'm getting real kick out
of this your title packs give you a
numbered plot of dedicated land on a
private estate in the medieval capital
city of scotland and an official
certificate with a crest and uh here's a
map where it is they have a special
lordship ladyship in kingdom of scotland
bundle which features a hand-drawn map
of scotland by famed cartographer john
speed they're also running a special
early black friday sale so go to
establishedtitles.com
new rockstars and get 10 off any orders
that's
establishedtitles.com new rockstars or
click the link in the description in
australia they find the corpse of a
deviant that gilgamesh had killed
recently karoon thinks it's beautiful
showing how beauty truly is a matter of
perspective but also making me suspect
that karoon could be a skrull who on the
scroll planet evolved from the deviant
race keep an eye on that one gilgamesh
compares coroon to alfred in batman one
of two references to dc superheroes in
this movie that's superman with the cape
and you're shooting laser beams out of
your eye now obviously the mcu
references uh external pop culture all
the time but dc references in particular
almost never come up in the mcu since
iron man in 2008 aside from a very quick
super prince reference in iron man 3 but
as i explained in a recent video and
confirmed by director chloe zhao
eternals is all about embracing
superhero mythology in general like
famous dc characters and characters like
thor all rooted in our world and in this
world in historical folklore and union
archetypes then suffering a bit of mad
weary athena remembers one of the past
planets they help the celestials destroy
saying everyone in century 6 is going to
die it's too late we can't save them
centuries 6 is actually a lesser planet
for marvel comics a planet whose
population ends up getting sold into
slavery gilgamesh and kingo both use
odin's name in place of god and then
kingo mentions thor thor used to follow
me around when he was a little kid
now he's a famous avenger and won't
return my calls
name thor and other asgardians may be
aware of the eternals on earth sprite's
illusions did earlier show a viking ship
and 575 bc would have been long before
norse vikings on earth were ever around
so she might have been referencing their
friends the asgardians and these two
groups of people might have known each
other which makes us now wonder what are
the celestial's relationship with
asgardians in the marvel comics the
asgardians were a special group that
celestials created from an extra
mutation cycle designed to reflect the
mythology of the people they protect so
we'll see if this history comes up in
thor love and thunder with characters
like gore the godbutcher who carries a
special sword that in the comics did
sever the head of the celestial nowhere
and they bring up the avengers so now
that captain rogers and iron man are
both gone who do you think's gonna lead
the avengers
i could lead them
[Music]
yeah they tell icarus that ajax didn't
even choose him to lead them and icarus
laughs it off but he does seem a bit
stung i think it's because he still
feels pretty guilty about what he did to
ajax it's also interesting that sprite
just called steve captain rogers meaning
they must have been aware of him back in
the 40s when he was still an army
soldier maybe also a nod to the fact
that captain american mcu is now
technically sam wilson are shem reveals
the dark truth to cersei that the
emergence is the hatching of a sleeping
celestial nestled inside earth called
tiamut and then all the celestials are
born by gestating inside host planets
feeding on the energy of the planet's
life forms and then emerge when they
reach a critical energy level and then
the celestials recycle that energy to
create new suns in new galaxies so
tiamat being secretly buried inside
earth comes directly from the marvel
comics in which timothe the dreaming
celestial arises from under san
francisco also gotta say nice to call
one accurately for a change aeroshem
shows him crashing up through the crest
of the earth shortly after the planet's
population resurges after bruce banner
ended the blip in avengers end game and
in that moment you can see specific
population centers suddenly repopulating
including a little bright spot on
wakanda as tiamat's giant hand reaches
up through the surface you can see the
city electrical grids suddenly
flickering out just a frightening
example of scale in the billions of
lives that would have been lost
airstream also reveals that the eternals
are not from the planet olympia but they
are actually memoryless synthetic beings
sent to host planets with celestial
seeds in order to make sure intelligent
life continues to evolve protecting that
life from the deviants whom the
celestials also created initially sent
to clear out the apex predators on that
planet aerisha mentions losing control
the deviants as they evolved and we see
what looks like some scrolls these
shape-shifting squirrels were actually
the deviant race on that planet thus the
link with the deviants more less
developed shape-shifting abilities in
this movie the eternals are constructed
in a world forge that stores their
memories from past lives cersei actually
sees an assembly line of her past selves
production design evoking the partly
formed ai robots in the movie ex machina
so at this point the movie may be where
eternals either loses you or hooks you
for me hook line and sinker i mean
similar to the way terence malik's tree
of life departs its earthbound drama for
a macroscopic interlude halfway through
the movie this sudden expository
spectacle is designed to stun and to
overwhelm us make us ask ourselves well
what do we matter then and in the case
of the story to shock cersei into blind
trembling obedience
just like our book of genesis is really
designed to do folks
waiting for someone or something to show
you the way
really posing this movie's deeper
question can one's purpose be defied for
love a debate that plays out among the
eternals kingo argues we're not the bad
guys we did our jobs one thing i really
love about this movie the conflict
arises from everyone pursuing their
purpose be it survival reproduction or
protection it's an elemental darwinian
struggle a battle of justifiable ideals
it actually evokes a classic greek drama
like escalus is the humanities in which
immortal greek gods debate the sins and
worthiness of the human mortals it's the
same debate of free will versus
determinism playing out with loki and
kang with the watcher of what if and it
raises the bar of intellect in the mcu
and i am here for it ultimately cersei
sides with the rationale cap used in
infinity war that the lives of others
are never worth trading therefore the
emergence must be stopped and they find
druid in a remote village of the amazon
mind controlling humans an idyllic cult
free from conflict it's actually kind of
fun to see how humanity is evolving in
its own microcosm there there's a
blacksmith hammering away reminding us
of tony stark in the cave in the first
iron man we hear cersei's ringtone it's
lizzo's juice and kingo and druid face
off bingo didn't vista i've directed
some things too yeah gingo says he's
made some online content but doesn't do
it for the views hey neither do we can
go i'm just kidding we totally do over
the views we are horny for views here we
are the arrows of views cersei tells
dane to call his uncle and make amends
with him and nodded dane whitman's uncle
nathan garrett in the comics the
previous black knight who's actually a
villainous character historically the
bear of the ebony blade not a good guy
which is why dane may not get along with
him in the comics dane actually inherits
a castle from his uncle and that's where
he finds the ebony blade in fact i think
that's where that second post-credits
scene is taking place then deviants
attacked the village kingo uses his
finger guns to explode one of their
heads while cersei turns another into a
tree showing that she actually can
transform sentient beings despite her
belief otherwise but the alpha deviant
kills gilgamesh and absorbs his life
force turning that deviant into a more
humanoid talking form named crow the
leader of the deviants in the comics
who's voiced by pennywise actor bill
skarsgard who accuses the eternals of
hunting his kind saying you are not
saviors eternals you are murderers and
you'll float too
but since jury doesn't think he's
powerful enough to mind control a whole
celestial they decide to seek out fastos
whom we flash back to at the site of
hiroshima august 8 1945 the day american
forces dropped an atomic bomb on the
city and standing in the ashes ajax
consoles fastos who cries i did this if
my technology hadn't helped in the past
drug was right this was a mistake these
people they're not worth saving his
regret is based on that of j robert
oppenheimer one of the scientists whose
research led to the atomic bomb
something he deeply regretted and
fiercely criticized in his later years
now fastos lives with his husband ben
and son jack who mistakes icarus for
superman fastos tells his family that
their names are isaac and sylvia a nod
to their human aliases in the comics
isaac ike harris and sylvia cersei on
the table is a star wars book now star
wars has already popped up in the mcu
before peter parker is obsessed with
star wars he cites empire and civil war
he collects star wars legos and
figurines and then of course cap list
star wars in his notebook but here along
with a superman reference it's just
another piece of pop culture rooted in
eternal linked mythology like george
lucas definitely based luke skywalker's
hero's journey on arthurian legend the
same arthur known by the eternals and by
dane's ancestors testing the walls of
fastosa's safe house icarus also tested
the table i bet you've built the perfect
safe house what's this even made of
vibranium
for icarus to assume fastos made a table
out of vibranium just another example
how things like wakanda vibranium tech
might have been aided by fastos and he
may have been the source who supplied
howard stark with that vibranium for
capped shield in world war ii but then
maybe quit helping the united states
defenses when they used his vision
technology for the manhattan project as
fastos leaves his family skeeter davis
is the end of the world plays which we
heard in the first trailer and then they
return to the iraqi archaeological dig
site where the ruins of babylon do rest
in our world as unesco world heritage
site here he raises the domo from the
earth and inside they find makari whom
gingko calls miss havisham a reference
to the crazy old hoarder from charles
dickens great expectations makari is
wearing a shirt for h.g wells war of the
worlds if you think about it a pretty
similar plot about extraterrestrial
world enders who end up not being able
to cut it because the germs on this
planet are just too resistant now as a
speedster makari has apparently just
gathered various historical artifacts
including an ancient egyptian statue of
the deity bastet who is an influence on
the wakandan panther deity of bost a
painting called le lezande musique which
actually hangs in the louvre a roman
imperial eagle staff with spqr synotist
populist k romanus the people's republic
of rome a bundle of scrolls maybe from
the lost library of alexandria a big mac
in its carton the holy grail the same
design from indiana jones of the last
crusade a statue called the chimera of
orezzo which in real life resides in the
national archaeological museum in
florence a throne that i thought might
have been the united kingdom's saint
edward's chair their throne but it's not
that one it's just one similar to it in
a medieval suit of armor one that you
might find in the uk's tower of london
remember happy hogan and the rest using
some of that armor to fend off the stark
drones and then a playstation vr headset
venus swings around a sword that sprite
thinks is the ebony blade again dane
whitman's black knights family sword but
beena corrects her it's excalibur the
sword of king arthur from legend and
sprite says while arthur always did have
a crush on you meanwhile the others
trade twinkies for the emerald tablet
showing that makari did eventually get
her hands on it bastos invents new
bracelets to help them form the uni mine
to hack tiamet which is the term for all
the eternals combining their
consciousness into a big brain that can
fight off other big forces in the comics
we flashback six days before when icarus
visited ajax on her ranch where she
tells him about the oncoming emergence
and he's like awesome great mission
accomplished let's pack it home boys but
she says five years ago thanos delayed
the emergence now since we just learned
that thanos and his brother eros were
both eternals of titan this may reframe
thanos's goal of erasing half of all
life across the universe instead as a
way of disrupting celestial reproduction
i've said it before i'll say it again
thanos did nothing wrong he had a plan
the guy was on our side had we only
listened but since ajak was a softy who
wanted to stop the emergence icarus
transports her to the worst place on
earth alaska just kidding i've never
been there but there's a melted glacier
with some oil workers being fed on by
unfrozen deviants but the deviants now
attack ajax killing her stealing her
healing power and then regrouping
spreading south now as the emergence
begins makari zips all around the world
looking for that hatching point i love
the way they depict her speedster
abilities in this movie the world zips
past her rapidly including we see her
past the christ the redeemer statue in
rio de janeiro as opposed to often how
we see speedsters in other movies where
they use relative slow motion to show
super speed both look really cool this
is just a whole new way of showing it i
really appreciated it and then she finds
that point at an island in the indian
ocean and if you look behind her in the
background there are a couple oil
platforms drilling away i love this
detail just gives this battle a backdrop
of a reminder of just one way part of
humanity doesn't care about this planet
that the eternals are fighting to save
icarus reveals his betrayal of ajac and
sprite ends up siding with him of course
she does now kingo i thought was
interesting does side with icarus in
theory he can't let go of his function
but out of not wanting to hurt his
family he benches himself from the fight
sprite houdini's herself and icarus out
of here actually in the credits montage
there is a poster for a houdini magic
show with sprite whispering in his ear
suggesting she might have influenced the
great magician and escape artist so
backup plan vastos has to extract
cersei's fear as kind of a backdoor hack
to tiamat setting up this final battle
on the volcanic island icarus crashes
the domo cersei stalls the eruption
makari infastos use some awesome moves
to pin icarus to hold him down ajax
seems to appear to cersei but it's all a
trick by sprite who stabs her in the
back and the drag club sprite in the
head lena battles crow in a cave and
manages to conjure blades to slice them
apart but still team it emerges it looks
epic in scale i loved how this looked
and cersei has to combine her strength
with the others of the uni mind to
reverse midas tiamat and turn his golden
form into marble icarus breaks free of
fastus's restraints and angrily fires
his laser eyes into the sky evoking an
iconic frame of icarus from the comics
icarus watches us go down and memories
of cersei rewind through their time
together back to their wedding day back
to babylon and to the first moment they
set eyes on earth while they were still
in its orbit and cersei said it's
beautiful isn't it beautiful the same
word icarus taught himself to say in
acadian or babylonia whatever version of
the language it was back then to cersei
the day that he proposed and so he
fulfills his mythological destiny and
flies way too close to the sun like like
way too close like into it but despite
this final conflict cersei can't help
but feel grateful to the celestial she
just killed on the day of its birth
crediting it for her successful unimine
link she says tiamat joined our unimine
we became one even with icarus and
sprite and that's all because of teemit
just interesting to think that tiamat
might have been okay with what cersei
was doing to it like not all celestials
are on board with arashim's way of doing
things and might be more willing to
grant the underlings like the eternals
more free will just gives us hope for
whatever celestial eros is about to
summon with his sphere answering the
question of this movie's premise our
original purposes can be and should be
defied for love and in the post-credits
scene we learn it's all thanks to the
god of love cersei turns sprite human
allowing her the chance to grow into an
adult and live the mortal life she
always wanted happy ending from another
classic fairy tale pinocchio and the
blue fairy and there are no strings on
her hey that's an ultron thing athena
departs earth on the domo alongside
druig and makari they're all seeking out
eternals on other planets while kingo
sprite and cersei's stay on earth but in
the final scene as dane begins to tell
cersei that his family history is
complicated and that it is his
birthright to be the black knight clouds
form in the sky and areshem appears
zipping cersei up to him along with
bastos in kingo telling them you have
chosen to sacrifice a celestial for the
people of this planet i will spare them
but your memories will determine if they
are worthy to live and i will return in
judgment allowing hershem to complete
his arc to become his title from the
comics irishman the judge
so this way the film kind of leaves it
open-ended whether humanity is worthy of
its salvation almost like a challenge to
us to earn our right to exist now if the
movie eternals didn't speak to you it's
totally okay but is it the worst marvel
movie hell no my friends this film's
deeper themes hit me hard and i believe
we will see the benefits of its
contributions for years to come in the
mcu but i want to know your thoughts on
the film in the comments below you can
support new rock stars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow me
rockstars and subscribe for breakdowns
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you